bonjour jean marc bonjour vous heureuse
de vous retrouver dans cette matinale
alors est-ce que ce plan macro pour la
france de 2030 est ce que c'est un vrai
projet simplement une promesse
électorale ça va quand même coûté 30
milliards oui bah écoutez c'est
peut-être un peu des deux
projets d'un côté promesses électorales
oui c'est les deux à la fois le plan
investissement à long terme vient
prolonger un peu amplifié ce qui avait
été fait pendant le coc vide il va
s'ajouter aux mesures de soutien qui ont
permis à la majorité des entreprises de
respirer y en a quand même eu pour 200
milliards environ puis au plan de
relance de juillet dernier qui a permis
lui de faire redémarrer la machine 100
milliards les deux opérations plutôt
assez bien fonctionné parce que on nous
avait quand même annoncé une catastrophe
économique et sociale avec une vague de
faillites une vague de chômage en fait
la reprise et et est bien réel tout est
reparti en provoquant même des blocages
qui sont liés à cette reprise on ne
trouve plus de matériaux de construction
on ne trouve plus de composants
électroniques et on assiste à des
pénuries de main d'oeuvre dans beaucoup
de secteurs je passe sur l'augmentation
du prix de l'énergie qui est imputable
directement à la reprise mondiale alors
le plan d'investissements annoncés par
emmanuel macron est un plan à long terme
puisqu'il vise 2030 donc emmanuel macron
sera plus de toute façon président
puisqu'il ne pourra faire que qu'un
deuxième mandat s'il se représente alors
oui on peut penser qu'il a annoncé cela
pour montrer qu'ils avaient de la
visibilité parce qu'on lui a souvent
reproché de gérer à court terme qui
s'occupait de l'avenir qu'ils étaient
conscients des problèmes et qu'ils
pouvaient dépasser l'horizon de son
mandat donc oui il ya un côté comme très
fort et un côté promesses électorales
mais disons nous la campagne électorale
a commencé fois et jean-marc justement
cette promesse elle est crédible ou pas
alors oui elle est lesquels les
promesses politiques n'engagent que ceux
qui les écoutent vous savez bien ce
qu'on dit mais le projet est quand même
logique il porte des informations qui
sont quand même intéressante à regarder
de près premier point il assume la
mutation digital en mettant le paquet
sur les investissements dans la
technologie électronique ou même dans la
biotechnologie on a des compétences on a
des experts et puis s'en vont faute de
pouvoir créer des entreprises en france
donnait bien vu ce qui s'est passé pour
les vaccins multiples qui ont découvert
le vaccin arn ils viennent de france ils
ont créé modern à l'étranger avec le
finder il faut qu'il reste donc il faut
leur donner un cadre national deuxième
point il assume la mutation climat très
fort alors là vraiment un côté
électorale mais ça correspond aussi à
une réalité en poussant l'électrique
automobile notamment avec le projet de
fabrication de batteries pour avoir
notre indépendance en matière de là il
ouvre la porte à l'hydrogène qui
l'appelle l'hydrogène vert mais enfin
cette ville roja dont tout le monde sait
que ce sera l'énergie de l'avenir enfin
troisième point il relance et ça c'est
important le programme nucléaire et ça
c'est très important parce que si
l'énergie de l'avenir c'est
l'électricité ou l'hydrogène mais ça
revient au même parce que l'hydrogène
pour la fabriquer il faut d'électricité
beaucoup d'électricité donc le moyen le
moins cher le plus propre aujourd'hui
dans le monde de fabriquer de
l'électricité c'est encore des centrales
nucléaires alors là il ouvre la porte et
normalement on aura avant les élections
présidentielles prochaines ou après
peut-être l'annoncent d'une relance
forte de nucléaire qui coûtera lui
beaucoup plus cher que les fameux 30
milliards dont il a parlé parce que on
ne peut pas s'en sortir autrement si on
perd nos petits l'on perd notre
indépendance alors on fragilise
l'ensemble de robes également si on
n'allait pas profiter de notre actif
l'europe nous achète aujourd'hui le
nucléaire et nous attend sur le
nucléaire et maintenant la question est
de savoir évidemment qui va payer tout
ça bah oui alors ça pour l'instant
l'endettement de la france a l'air de
panique et certains responsables
politiques même edouard philippaerts la
semaine dernière aux fans week-end
dernier d'avis que la france devra
régler ce problème budgétaire ça
rappelle françois fillon vous ce n'est
qu'il disait déjà été premier ministre
il était premier d'une france en
faillite alors aujourd'hui la dette
publique va dépasser les 120 % du pib à
la fin de l'année donc toutes les normes
européennes maastricht elles sont
enfoncés et tout le monde s'en inquiète
parce qu'on ne sait pas comment on le
fera aux frappes au pays et est ce qu'il
faut sans m'inquiéter jean-marc alors
écoutez je suis très perplexe je le
crois pas d'ailleurs la majorité des
économistes vous eh bien nous serons peu
ne s'inquiète pas de la dette la dette
est à très long terme et on n'a pas la
rembourser d'un seul coup on a dix
quinze vingt ans peut-être pour le faire
cette dette et financer à taux zéro ou à
taux négatifs nous trouvons sur le
marché de l'épargné nécessaire à ce prix
là pourquoi s'en priver il serait
stupide de ne pas s'endetter à ce prix
là alors il faudra la rembourser oui
mais la croissance économique va le
faire mécaniquement chaque année vers un
petit exercice si votre dette beaucoup
de zéros et si votre économie vous
rapporte chaque année disons 3% et bien
votre stock de dettes va diminuer de 3%
mécaniquement alors ce petit miracle ne
fonctionnera qu'à deux conditions 1 il
faut que le stock de dette soit stable
faut surtout pas en augmenter
interdiction de l'accroître deuxième
condition il faut que la dette soit
investi et que cet investissement génère
des revenus et de la croissance des
fameux 3% alors là on n'est pas très
fort en france on n'est pas très fort
dans la gestion de la dette on emprunte
assez facilement pour régler des
dépenses sociales des dépenses de
fonctionnement les dépenses
administratif j'ajoute qu'on est assez
mal équipé pour que les investissements
publics soit générateur de profits et
donc de croissance c'est bien d'engager
des grands travaux mais il faut pas se
louper faut pour être il faut près
peut-être mieux les confier à des gens
qui connaissent le métier peut être le
privé alors là on entre dans un autre
débat il est pas ouvert mais il est très
politique fuir merci beaucoup c'était
très clair merci et jean marc sylvestre
était l'édito époux de la matinale